no you started your Tuesday at 2:00 p.m.
you know when you're drinking because
you're stressed and then you get drunk
by surprise yeah that happened last
night you know your life is different
now okay all right I woke up so hungover
today and I couldn't think of a video
ideas I thought we'd just do this
thought I would just sit down today and
show you guys how I do my makeup on days
when I'm wildly hungover to trick others
into thinking I'm not so the first thing
I normally do is spend hours in bed in a
cloud of my own regret I spared you
don't worry I did that I've already
off-camera now we're gonna shower our
hair this is what a role model looks
like this morning I found out that I had
a scab on my scalp and I have no idea
where that's from
life should be about constant
self-discovery okay now let's fix the
face most times I wash my face but just
taking some toner and slapping it on the
skin that's saying please just take care
of me
yum-yum-yum skin get all about catch me
why you gotta be so rude don't you know
I'm garbage too I know you guys are
probably sick of how many makeup videos
there have been lately and I'm not a
doctor I can't heal your sickness I'm
sorry then I think this boot product
placement this is called in late super
face wake up eyes cooling i invigorate
err this came free in a swag bag from an
event do I think it's great I don't know
but I have it okay that goes under our
eyes my winter 2017 look is Haggard and
I use this this was in my favorites
video is Evan Healey lemon time facial
tonic and I just spray it on my face and
say erase the mistakes and extinct so it
feels kind of like a punishment for the
choices I've made then we did this
because we're her biggest fan I wash my
hands before doing this nope hey what's
next a check on our Amazon Prime now
order the other thing I did before this
was make myself a Corona and cheese and
eat 3/4 of a box I earned it absolutely
not so now let's start painting our
masks on our face so we can prank
everyone make them think that we didn't
shower and vodka last night not at all I
just got you and your show what's got me
already
Barry I'm Brandon I've been using this
Garnier BB cream 5 and 1
called skin perfector she could use a
miracle today that's what she could use
I use this kind of as a base and then I
put regular foundation on top
mmm just slap it on that we are capable
we are not good at coming up with mantra
songs our charm is in our sloppy fluffy
human Muppet nests we say to ourselves
over and over now I put foundation on I
found this Revlon youth effects filling
blur foundation oh but I didn't pick the
right color for me as per usual so I
just kind of mix it with another
foundation I have just pop it on there
okay our poor decision-making has been
reduced by a fair amount all righty
let's get the under eye it's better
let's turn these under-eye bags into
under-eye Jack's acquires Jaguars
something people want
we're you gonna use this NYX dark circle
in talking is hard next dark circle
concealer fan and we're just gonna pile
it on there I don't I just kind of blend
it with the Beauty Blender and then whoa
look who's gonna make people think she
actually got REM sleep last night
Hey now let's what do we do a general
life question really ah let's work on
eyebrows I just got this soap & Glory
thing for eyebrows it's called archery
two-in-one brow and I like him very much
it's got a little spooley with like brow
gel on one side and then a pencil on the
other and what I do but the gel on first
then I put the brows stuff on then I put
more gel on that's excessive and
probably completely unnecessary but it's
just what I do
excessive and unnecessary it's also a
very good idea for it the name of a
perfume oh my prime now might be coming
soon okay but that's at a second and I
use the pencil and they go over it and
they make them look like eyebrows I
forgot about talking and trying to
entertain at the same time oh look who's
curious and coy and kind of flirty and
creepy hey what's next is your battery
is low so let's change that
what's symbolism okay we're gonna do
maybe kind of an overcompensating look
because we're not
wanna trick others you want to trick
ourselves into thinking we're put
together everything's on track the way
it should be and we do anything we put
our minds to like bring ourselves into
the present day hangover I'm gonna use
the same Kiley eyeshadow palette that I
used in my sexy fall makeup thing
there's been so many makeup videos sorry
I'm in an era of liking makeup for half
a second I'm gonna tone it down a little
bit it's not gonna be so heavy-handed so
I'm going to take this one very
descriptive and put it under my eyebrow
bone and then in a tear duct some people
think whoa she's bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed no say some wobbly then I
take the next on the shimmery and I put
that one all over the eyelid just
smearing it all over this damn will take
maybe these two Browns mix a little bit
and put them in the crease Oh
everybody's blend it up looks like one
of those Instagram makeup artists did
their own makeup with their non-dominant
hand fun talking talking talking
alright that's a thing fine enough fine
is the goal maybe we'll do some liquid
liner why not
this is NYX epic ink liner I love this
liquid liner it rules so we're gonna use
it talk amongst yourselves I'll give you
a topic each one of you should try and
get two people to subscribe to my
youtube channel because it's fun all
right
whoa she's awake this is always a gamble
to see if they look like they're related
yeah again fine we'll take it all right
now we do eyelashes hold on we're gonna
playing Trixie's today at some
individual lashes but sets of three and
I'm gonna put on some fake lashes
because we're going for it I just wanna
put a quick layer of mascara on this is
the falsies volume Express false feels
appropriate this is definitely very old
and probably shouldn't be being put on
my eye lashes because of bacteria but we
ourselves are a petri dish of lord knows
why I'm pretty bad at doing this so this
is likely just another bad decision but
mm-hmm
we're gonna push our luck oh no no
a bad idea okay
ha then why are we doing this try though
sex
no one's stressed up everyone's having
fun you know the fun boys get in and
play with other lashes mother good
enough good enough good enough I Amazon
Prime now is gonna be here in a second
Todd aha prime now delivery received and
he had no idea I was hungover well not
done yet maybe a little bit of an idea
the struggle saga is over they're on
we're gonna put a little more mascara on
just to blend them in don't know if
that's really necessary but people do it
I'm using this other mascara that I
think is less bacteria filled Oh it's
cover girls
total tease by the way for anyone that
gives a [ __ ] to our bottom lashes -
because everyone gets touched by
products today look at our products it's
a great makeup base so pop your name now
put some bronzer on I use this bronze
colors bronzing face powder oh and I
like it so much
I broke the lid off of it I'm a monster
bronzer we've been bronzed we've been
kissed with consent by the Sun wash
let's put blush on music due to you from
NARS it's also in my last favorites
video and it makes me feel like a giant
when I hold it so coy then let's put
some setting powder on I have this NYX
HD finishing powder
oh so scummy and dirty I like to
sometimes just take my Beauty Blender
and put it in and put the powder on okay
now all we need is a lip color look you
see you this is Clinique chubby stick
keeping hazelnut keeping haze on that
more like weeping Helbig is nuts there
we go this is my everyday let's hide the
mistakes away hangover makeup look who's
this girl not full of regret that's what
you got pranked I wouldn't trust this
person to make good choices
hey guys spent this video if you liked
it give it a thumbs up leave a comment
down below what's your go-to hangover
routine make sure you subscribe to this
YouTube channel click that button if you
haven't already and hit that Bell
notification so you know when I post
videos because I'm trying to post Monday
through Friday but the time of day in
which the posting happens
mmm berries so get notified I don't know
you can bring a horse to water but you
can't teach it to drink because this
horse already knows how to drink
something like that right